[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono una donna pacata ma anche
determinata e risoluta un imprenditrice
nel mondo della Meccanica di precisione
avvezza ad avere che fare con operai
dalle mani dure con sindacati con
managers con le esigenze dei clienti e
dei fornitori con
commercialisti consulenti avvocati dai
nomi altisonanti
il 2 marzo del 2017 mi trovavo in
azienda come sempre del resto e mio
marito ora mio ex marito cose che
capitano nella vita mi avverte che mi ha
cercato la dottoressa Di Chiara mia
figlia che all'epoca aveva 13 anni dice
che devo richiamarla
pronto dottoressa cosa succede
percepisco un silenzio pesante
dall'altro capo del telefono
è sufficiente Quell'attimo di esitazione
della voce della dottoressa e mi si
scatena un brivido una scossa elettrica
lungo la schiena
mi ascolti signora vada a casa Prepari
una borsa per la notte
prelevi Chiara da scuola è andata al
Policlinico ingresso 2 settimo piano vi
aspettano
io che ho inquadrato la mia vita in una
ferrea logica di causa effetto non posso
certo accontentarmi di quelle parole
insisto chiedo chiarimenti
gli esami di routine che sua figlia ha
fatto mostrano qualcosa di preoccupante
che va subito indagato meglio
In che senso preoccupante
Mi spiace dirlo in questo modo ma i dati
emersi potrebbero essere segnale di una
malattia del sangue molto seria
È probabile che sua figlia abbia la
leucemia
Come si reagisce a una telefonata di
questo tipo io ho reagito meccanicamente
ho fatto tutto quello che la dottoressa
mi ha detto di fare come un automa casa
valigia scuola Chiara ospedale ingresso
2 settimo piano
pareti colorate
infermieri Medici
bambini con gli occhi tristi bambini con
la flebo
bambini Calvi
ricovero Biopsia al midollo la biopsia
conferma leucemia
susteinability la capacità di reggere
agli urti nel tempo
Che Guevara diceva siate realisti
desiderate l'impossibile
da quel 2017 molte cose sono cambiate in
me nella mia vita
ho desiderato l'impossibile e ho
combattuto per averlo
per quasi quattro anni oltre Mille
giorni ho osservato un parcheggio
come un pesce in una palla di vetro Ho
sfruttato il mondo esterno attraverso la
finestra di una camera di ospedale e ho
visto una colata di cemento
che a ben guardare racchiude il senso
della vita
alla mattina il parcheggio si sveglia si
anima si riempie di persone per poi
lasciare lo spazio alla calma del
tramonto e al buio della notte
nascita esistenza morte
per oltre Mille giorni ho guardato
l'alba su una colata di cemento e ho
atteso con una tossica la mia dose di
vita
ho riflettuto su quelli che si
definiscono normalmente valori ho messo
in discussione molte delle mie idee
ho scoperto di avere pregiudizi
mi sono trovata faccia a faccia con le
mie paure sono uscita dalla mia zona di
sicurezza
ho capito la differenza tra l'essere
rigida E l'essere solida una cosa rigida
rischia di spezzarsi una cosa solida
resiste agli urti perché porta dentro di
sé i significati di forza e di
flessibilità
Albert Einstein diceva la vita è come
andare in bicicletta per rimanere in
equilibrio devi muoverti per me è stato
fondamentale allenare la mia capacità di
essere flessibile come un atleta che fa
seduta di stretching con piccoli
puntuali e lenti movimenti che inducono
grandi cambiamenti
ho sviluppato mi è vecchie e nuove
abilità facendo ciò che mi era concesso
fare in una camera di ospedale
ho letto molti libri biografie
soprattutto perché mi affascinano la
vita delle altre persone
ho frequentato corsi online di scrittura
di Style coach di inglese
ho giocato con gli outfit con le tute
colorate con i calzini Scemi con i
codini da bambina per far sorridere mia
figlia
durante i mesi estivi immaginavamo che
il rumore dell'acqua della doccia fosse
lo scroscio delle onde del mare che
letto dell'ospedale con la testata
rialzabile fosse il lettino sulla
spiaggia e che l'asta della flebo fosse
il nostro ombrellone
su steinability ogni situazione ha
sempre due facce che vanno osservate con
attenzione prima di darne una qualsiasi
valutazione
scegliere la strada che sia più
sostenibile per noi e per il contesto in
cui viviamo sempre
Mia figlia ha capito subito che quello
che le stava succedendo era una cosa
seria
poco dopo la scoperta della sua malattia
sicuramente sola con le sue paure ha
preso carta e penna e ha scritto a
caratteri stampatello maiuscolo
le cose che voglio fare prima di morire
superfluo dire cosa ho provato quando
una mattina riassettando la stanza ho
trovato quel foglio ma messa da parte la
mia angoscia mi sono detta Ok Sono
pronta facciamolo
e così nei 5 lunghi e dolorosi anni
della sua malattia ho sempre tenuto bene
a mente quel foglio cercando in tutti i
modi possibili anche più rocamboleschi
di realizzare ogni punto di quella lista
gettarsi col parapendio fare un viaggio
con i nonni avere una dondolo in
giardino andare a un concerto fare il
ballo delle debuttanti con un bel abito
bianco in accademia qui a Modena
su steinability sostituire la parola
speranza parola dannatamente dannosa
perché fa rima con aspettative quando le
aspettative si infrangono la caduta fa
molto male
sostituirla dicevo con la parola
desiderio
avere un desiderio significa essere
pronti ad assumerne il costo della sua
realizzazione
significa
impegno dedizione fatica ma alla sua
realizzazione proveremo un piacere vero
profondo non effimero
se si analizzano i freddi numeri quelli
che Ironia della sorte mi hanno sempre
affascinato quelli che ho studiato
quando ero giovane quelli nei quali ho
creduto di trovare certezze e sicurezza
la malattia di mia figlia è un fatto
raro una malattia che incide
relativamente poco sulla comunità
ogni anno in Italia si ammalano di un
tumore oncoematologico 400 bambini su un
milione
l'85% di questi bambini guarisce
mia figlia è caduta nella parte
sbagliata della percentuale
una dottoressa speciale come ho avuto la
fortuna di incontrarne tante sul mio
percorso una mattina quando tutto stava
per crollare mi ha sussurrato
all'orecchio
mamma quello che le sta per accadere può
essere un macigno che la trascinerà
nell'abisso
o può diventare un'energia che la farà
brillare di luce
Il dolore è una delle nostre emozioni
fondamentali a una propria funzione
fisiologica esistenziale è il segnale
che siamo vicini a un punto di rottura o
se la rottura c'è già stata indica che
si è rotto un equilibrio
Il regno del dolore è il presente
su steinability allenare la nostra forza
affinché il dolore ci faccia Meno male
possibile
accettare di soffrire per smettere di
soffrire
E come dice un proverbio indiano
trasformare le lacrime in perle
[Applauso]